so I'm so curious about this there's so
much magic in this movie not just what
you see on screen but in how the movie
was made and this must have been a
really unique acting experience for you
so you gotta let me behind the curtain a
bit like how did you become Tinkerbell
are you are you a lot of CG character
are you on harnesses and ropes flying
around a studio like what was it well a
lot of the magic happened in Vancouver
where I was not
um
uh they had built these incredibly epic
and immersive sets uh in Canada and then
they did quite a bit of traveling for it
but for me I was shooting in Los Angeles
and I was
um I was considered motion capture as
how they did the technology for
Tinkerbell and basically what that is is
I go in and I give my performance but
then because they have to shrink me and
make me fly and all these things they
have to recreate the whole thing
digitally based on my performance and so
it was quite funny because when I first
signed on to the project there was a
world where I was supposed to be on
wires and on a blue screen and taking
Cirque de Soleil classes and such but
when it when it got down to it so much
of it was about the facial performance
and then the kind of upper body
performance so I'd I'd have to sit
actually very still and just respond
with my face and then I'd go to like a
different part of the set and just kind
of do the body movement and motion part
uh to think about like how would
Tinkerbell land how would Tinkerbell
fight how would Tinkerbell try and find
a shadow
crazy that's so cool though so again
you'll just have to do the Cirque du
Soleil stuff on your own time
essentially so it was a lot of thumping
around in my room if I'm being honest
I'm sure my brothers thought like what
is happening in there just because
before any sort of Tinkerbell filming
day it was a lot of just kind of trying
to get into the zone of what her
movements are you know there still has
to be kind of an element of levity to
her because she's always flying and so
that was really interesting because that
even came down to posture and saying
like well Tinkerbell would never just
kind of be sitting like this even if
that feels more comfortable because
she's half up in the air every time she
does something
um so yeah it was a lot of fine tuning
it and finding it with our director
David uh who is just so wonderful and we
had a lot of fun playing and finding
what made Tinkerbell feel special very
cool well I mean it's particularly
interesting for you too because you
communicate
when your facial expressions almost and
your in your body almost exclusively in
this thumb
yeah absolutely and so that was uh quite
a fun Challenge and I think if anything
a real welcome difference you know as an
actor I was going between Tinkerbell and
grownish and in grownish I mean my
character will never be quiet she has so
much to say and I love her dearly I love
Zoe Johnson but you know I not only
speak to camera I have monologues I'm
doing voice over everything about my
characters about how much she has to say
and how she's communicating her point of
view so to go from that to playing a
character that it has super limited ways
of communicating with people
um was really fun to try and hack
because one I forget how many of how
much of my facial expressions still rely
on me being able to communicate what I'm
saying versus what does it look like if
you know that no one around you is going
to be able to understand you and so how
much bigger are you or what do those
facial expressions look like or how
frustrated are you half the time when
it's like well that's not what I tried
to say and of course here we go again no
one's understanding me
um but I enjoyed I enjoyed that
now when you were a kid were you the
kind of kid that couldn't wait to grow
up or did you want to stay a kid forever
I think I was definitely a stay a kid
forever camp like I didn't get my
license until right before I turned 21
because I just had I was like where am I
going there's nowhere to go
um happy where I am and
um I I think I've just so enjoyed I had
such a childhood full of Adventure and
I I think there were definitely moments
of seeming anxiety thinking that I had
to live up to certain things of what it
meant to be an adult and so now being 23
so much of uh being 23 for me has been
figuring out the fact that I I get to
Define what this era of adulthood looks
like for me and so the things that I
loved about being a kid don't have to
magically disappear because I'm older
um and so now it's been great and now
it's been great but yeah I was in the
Never Grow Up camp
I gotta say it was so fun seeing you in
this graduations again on the movie uh
and for the record my 9 year old
daughter said she could understand you
perfectly so of course she could she
gets it tell her congratulations on this
Epic like Epic film it must have been so
cool to see yourselves as Peter and
Wendy for the very first time costume on
on set what was that first day like
knowing that you were taking on these
roles Alexander I think a lot of
pressure uh at first uh portraying this
character who people have known and
loved for so many years all over the
world uh but I think seeing myself in
the costume I well it felt right uh
first of all putting it on uh but just
looking at it I I thought wow I'm
actually doing this
yeah ever we've also got like a very
cool Twist on the story giving Wendy
um a lot of power a lot of agency in
this what was it like for you to be able
to tell this story this way
I felt so honored and it was such a it
was such a privilege to get to do this
and to get to show this take on a
character that's been beloved by so many
people around the world
now for both of you like was there going
back watching the older movies watching
any of the uh other adaptations or
really were those things you already
grew up with before you you know got on
board with this film I definitely grew
up being read The Storybook of Peter Pan
and Wendy The Jam Barry book and I grew
up on the animated classic yeah uh I
definitely grew up on the animated
classic as well uh and I'd read the book
when I was younger as well uh yeah it
played a key part of my childhood well
the the Disney Magic did yeah
um I thought it was pretty magical to
see Jude Law uh this way I've never
considered him as like a scary dude but
here he is playing one of the most
iconic villain characters ever what was
it like being with him on set was he in
character like the entire time Jude was
amazing uh I mean offset he was so kind
so easy to talk to and so down to earth
uh but then he transformed this menacing
character it was just amazing
yeah Alex said it very well he was the
scary pirate captain on set and then
offset he was this complete gentleman
and you would have never known it was
the same person
what do you guys think the biggest
challenges were for you both going into
this
for me probably well the stunts uh a lot
of effort went into those so we arrived
two months early uh and spent a long
time preparing flying and fighting but
definitely the outcome uh it was
definitely worth it
I think for me the biggest challenge was
getting the accent down
because obviously I don't actually have
a British accent so Direction was
perfect oh thank you but um I was
watching a lot of absolutely fabulous in
Monty Python and then working with a
dialect coach to get that
British accent of the era
and those are like the perfect things to
be watching absolutely
uh ever were you doing um line readings
with your mom was she like
being your I guess coach back and forth
what was what was the experience like
seeing your your dad and your mom watch
you in this
it was incredible
my parents gave me some amazing advice
going into this and yes me and my mom
did line readings for the audition for
the movie
it was more
we'd get on to set all of us and and
then wing it yeah and have a lot of fun
I didn't really do any line reading with
anyone when we were filming but
definitely for the audition I worked
with my mom on it
now I'm curious for both of you when you
were kids were you the type of kid that
was really really excited to just grow
up as fast as you could or did you think
you just wanted to stay a kid forever no
I don't want it to say a kid I I was
definitely playing the Peter Pan role uh
and I have never wanted to grow up and
it's just gone so fast uh well since
since we began filming and now we're
here it's it's crazy just childhood
memories sad
yeah whatever you were saying that you
didn't want to grow up no I didn't want
to grow up at all I loved being able to
have
a Carefree life where I got to eat off
the kids menu and nobody gave me any
funny looks and I was definitely in no
rush to grow up when I was younger
listen I'll still eat out the kids menu
when I get a chance uh congratulations
again both of you thank you so much for
the time cheers thank you